BARRÉ-BOULET BACK TO HEDMAN.
TO POINT.
STAMKOS AND REDIRECECHYSICAL, GR
SKIN AND PLAYS IN ALLTHE OTHER .
PATS UP TO CENTER AND IT'S
IMPRESSIVE.
TAKES IT FROM BACKHAND TO
FOREHANE
CALLED.
PAUL AGAINST STAMKOS IN THE
OTTAWA INTO ZUB
AND MATT MUR SPRING. LIGHTNING
AND THIS CAN BE MOMENTS OF SWING
GAMES, JAMIE.
>> Jamie:
A A SCENARIO WHERE YOU
THINK YOU HAVE YOUR SECECN BRIAN
ELLIOTOT
>> Gord: OFF THE DRAW.
ONDREJ PALAT A YOUR OWN
STONE.
IT HIT -- ZONE.
IT HIT SOMETHING AND OFF THE
SKATE OF
AND BUMPS THAT UP TO CENTER THEE
TAMPA BAY LIGHTNING.
UP THE WAL IT DOWN
KNOCKED AWAY BY MURRAY.
ELLIOTT MAKES THE
NOW HERE COMES MATHIEU JOSEPH
AGAIN.F
MATT MURRAY.
STAMKOS GETS BEHIND COVERAGE. B.
BRADY TKACHUK TO PALAT.
HE STEPS AROUND FRONT. GOAL TO .
UNANSWERED GOALS IN THE THIRD
PERIOD.
ZUB SHOOTS AND THAT GOES WIDE.
KELLY.
GOAL.
VICTOR METE IS GOING TO GET THE
PUCK OFF THE WALL AND THROW IT